[Music]
i'm the owner of a
salvage business and i have a job over
i want you to help me break into the
most secure vault in the world
okay very good you know who
francis drake was he stole the spanish
treasure and that's
what's in the bag untold wealth you
probably need a safe cracker
i'm an engineer i need your mind or
others to see an impossible task
you might see a solution
the war room meet the team a computer
wins
acquisitions planning and extraction
made one of the world's brightest minds
he's going to mastermind the
infiltration the vault what it is how it
works
we can't work it out no one has and if
we get caught
we're going down for a very long time
are you sure you're prepared for that
are you kids got bald
the bank of spain the most impenetrable
building on the planet
across the street the headquarters of
the spanish army on alert for any
attempts on the bank
when spain plays its world cup game
every camera will be pointing away from
the building
which gives us 105 minutes to get the
job done
simple stage one vault
keys
we need to abort no three two
one
last one he's a college kid
you are putting our lives in his hands
[Applause]
you're good
[Music]
you